two weeks since i last addressed you
from this podium
i'm pleased to report that we've
continued to make steady progress in our
collective
effort to beat the coronavirus for three
weeks now the number of new cases
identified
through testing each day has been below
a thousand the latest sage advice
is that across the uk the r rate remains
between 0.7 and 0.9
sage also assess that the number of
infections is shrinking by between five
and one percent every day the latest ons
data shows prevalence and new infections
to be stable
and low the number of patients newly
admitted to
hospital with coronavirus each day and
the number of chronovirus patients in
mechanical ventilation beds
have both fallen by more than 90 from
their peak in early april
and while we mourn every death the
average daily death rate continues
steadily
to fall this progress is testament to
the phenomenal efforts of our nhs and
social care staff working tirelessly on
the front line
and it has only been possible thanks to
the character and fortitude
with which you the british people have
made fundamental changes
to the way you all live and work
when we set out our plan to rebuild on
the 11th of may
we said that our goal was to return to
life as close to normal as possible
for as many people as possible as fast
and as fairly as possible in a way that
is safe and that
continues to protect our nhs
that goal remains the same but the tools
we use to achieve it
are changing at the start of the
pandemic
we knew far less about the nature and
the spread of the virus and we had to
take blanket
national measures national lockdown was
undoubtedly the right thing to do
and has saved many thousands of lives
now however we know more about the virus
we understand the epidemiology better
and our intelligence
on where it is spreading is vastly
improved
that means we can control it through
targeted local
action instead in england
this work is led by nhs test and trace
and
within it the joint bios security center
my deep thanks go to dido harding who
oversees this work
and who joins me today this approach is
already
working in western super mario and
kirklees we took swift and successful
action
to contain outbreaks at specific
premises in bradford and and blackburn
with darwin
we identified troubling trends in the
data and
worked closely with respective local
authorities to increase
testing and take targeted action
that work continues and in leicester
we instituted a local lockdown in order
to bear down
on stubborn rates of infection as the
health secretary announced
last night we will begin to relax the
restrictions there
next week we can do so because the data
is improving with the percentage of
people testing positive falling
from a weekly rate of 12.2 percent on
the 29th of june
to 4.8 percent yesterday
the approach varies in different parts
of the uk
but all parts of the uk benefit from the
support of our armed forces additional
testing facilities
and billions of pounds of support
provided by this government
today we are publishing our framework
for containing and controlling future
outbreaks
in england which will enable national
local government
to work closely together from tomorrow
local authorities will have new powers
in their areas they will be able to
close specific premises
shut public outdoor spaces and cancel
events these powers will enable local
authorities
to act more quickly in response to
outbreaks
where speed is paramount action by local
councils will not always be
sufficient so next week we'll publish
draft regulations which clearly set out
how
central government can intervene more
effectively at a
local level where justified by
the evidence ministers will be able to
close
whole sectors or types of premises in an
area
introduce local stay-at-home
orders prevent people entering or
leaving
defined areas reduce the maximum
size of gatherings beyond national rules
or restrict transport systems serving
local areas i know it will be hard going
for people affected by these
local measures it isn't easy and for
some it may seem
unjust that people just a short distance
away can live their lives
closer to normal but it has to be right
that we take local action in response
to local outbreaks there is no point in
shutting down a city in one part
of the country to contain an outbreak in
another part of the country now of
course
this local approach relies on having an
effective testing
regime in place and here we have made
substantial progress antigen test
capacity
that's the test which tells you if you
currently
have the virus has increased 100 fold
since the start of march from fewer than
two thousand tests a day
to more than two hundred thousand tests
a day now
publicly available data suggests we are
now carrying out our tests
more than anywhere else in europe in
total
and more tests than germany france italy
and spain
per capita we've set up testing sites
around the uk and now have 200 mobile
units
which can be rapidly deployed wherever
they're needed
it's now the case and it has been for
some time that anyone
anywhere in the uk with symptoms can get
a test
without delay we're also testing
increasing numbers of people who don't
have systems but who are
at higher risk
as we approach winter we will need to go
further
not least as many more people will show
covid like symptoms
as a result of seasonal illnesses and
therefore
require a test so we will further
increase testing capacity
to at least half a million antigen tests
a day
at 3.5 million antigen tests a week
by the end of october
demand for testing is not the only
challenge that winter will bring
it's possible that the virus will be
more
virulent in the winter months and it's
certain
that the nhs will face the usual annual
winter pressures we've taken a number of
steps therefore to get the nhs
ready for winter we have massively
increased the number of ventilators
available to patients
across the uk up from 9 000 before the
pandemic
to nearly 30 000 now
substantially increased the pipeline of
personal protective equipment
for the nhs and social care constituting
over 30 billion items
of ppe over the course of the pandemic
we will be rolling out the biggest ever
flu
vaccination program in the history of
the uk
we will also of course give the nhs
the resources it needs and today i can
confirm
that we're providing an additional three
billion pounds of funding to the nhs in
england
to get ready for winter scotland wales
and northern ireland
will also receive additional funds
this will allow the nhs to continue to
use the
extra hospital capacity acquired from
the independent sector
and also to maintain the nightingale
hospitals
until the end of march
this new funding comes on top of the
additional
30 billion pounds of funding for health
and social care that we've already
announced
this year so we're making sure
we're ready for winter and planning
for the worst but even as we plan
for the worst i strongly believe
we should also hope for the best
that means looking ahead with optimism
now extending our plan to lift the
remaining
national measures which have restricted
our lives since march
so we can get back to something closer
to normal life now i must stress
the timetable i am about to set out
is conditional it is contingent
on any every one of us staying alert
and acting responsibly
it relies on our continued success
in controlling the virus and we will not
proceed
if doing so risks a second peak that
would
overwhelm the nhs nonetheless
it is important to give people hope and
to give business confidence so in
england from today
we are making clear that anybody may use
public transport while of course
encouraging people to consider
alternative means of transport where
they are available
from the 25th of this month july we've
already committed
to reopening indoor gyms pools and other
sports
facilities from the first of august we
will
update our advice on going
to work instead of government
telling people to work from home we're
going to give
employers more discretion and ask them
to make decisions about how their staff
can work
safely that could mean of course
continuing
to work from home which is one way of
working safely
and which has worked for many employers
and employees
or it could mean making workplaces safe
by following covet secure guidelines
whatever employers decide they should
consult
closely with their employees and
only ask people to return to their place
of work
if it is safe
as we reopen our society and economy
it's right that we give employers more
discretion
while continue to ensure that employees
are kept safe also
from the 1st of august we will reopen
most remaining leisure settings
namely bowling skating rinks casinos
and we will enable close contact
services
uh beauty beauticians to resume
nightclubs soft play areas sadly need
to remain closed for now though this
will be kept
under review we will restart
indoor performances to a live audience
subject to the success of pilots
and we will also pilot larger gatherings
in venues
like sports stadia with a view to a
wider
reopening in the autumn
we will also allow wedding receptions
for up
to 30 people all of these measures
for the first of august should be done
in a coveted
secure way in september
schools nurseries and colleges will be
open for all children
and young people on a full time basis
as planned and universities are also
working to reopen
as fully as possible
from october we intend to bring back
audiences in stadia
and to allow conferences and other
business events to
recommence again these changes
must be done in a copied secure way
subject to the successful
outcome of pilots
throughout this period we will look to
allow more close contact
between friends and family where we can
it is my strong and sincere hope that we
will be able to review
the outstanding restrictions and allow
a more significant return to normality
from november at the earliest possibly
in time for christmas at all times we
will continue to work with the devolved
administrations in scotland wells and
northern ireland
to support and care for those at risk
wherever they live in the uk
we've said that the shielding programme
for those most at risk in england
the clinically extremely vulnerable will
be paused at the end of this month
we will stay constantly vigilant and be
sure to restart
shielding at any point if required now i
know
some will say this plan is too
optimistic that the risks are
too great and that we won't overcome
the virus in time and of course if they
are right
in saying that and we cannot exclude
that they are
let me reassure them and reassure you
that we will not hesitate at any stage
to put on the brakes
from may the 11th onwards this plan has
been
conditional and it remains conditional
but if we continue to pull together
as we have done so far i know we can
beat
this virus hoping for the best
but planning for the worst and it's in
that spirit
that we must carry on waging this long
hard fight
against coronavirus